I feel like I've consistently my whole
career not gotten work because people
are like oh he can only do that like
he's his stuff is funny but it's too
weird for us you know and and you're
like no I can do the other side I did
Role Models I do I've used exactly and
also I can I've I've done the range of
things over time and as you said the
brand can have
um a double edge to it and people like
oh he's the guy who just does like
really goofy dumb things and so we have
this thing that we have real feeling
about and it matters to us so there's no
way he could handle that do you just
feel like you have to fight more these
days for something you're passionate
about I've always generated my own stuff
um but I also do feel like yeah I think
just the natural progression and getting
older and I'm not in the I'm not in that
I'm not young anymore and I'm I feel
like I have to work harder to get heard
and that's fine